check out this story we have in the
Daily Mail judge findes Trump $5,000 for
calling his clerk Schumer's girlfriend
and now deleted truth social post so you
mean to tell me that after he was told
to shut up he retroactively then came
back and said okay now you got to pay me
money yeah so they made Trump be quiet
uh Trump deleted the post and now
they're finding him it says the judge
said it was a blatant violation of a gag
order preventing Trump from publicly
attacking his staff did he call her
Schumer again I don't so I don't think
he did it again I think it was just the
one time was that before he deleted it
but it also appeared on his campen
website H right this was the old post
that I I thought that was the pretext
for the for the gag it was yeah the he
didn't he didn't want him uh engoron is
that how you say his name engoron I
guess uh did not want Trump saying mean
things about his staff okay so that was
the mean thing that caused him to want a
gag or order yes and then after the gag
order he went back and is now finding
Trump for this post that he had erased
yeah cuz it looks like it was also on
his campaign website hey this is just
the beginning he's gonna the I think the
judges are going to do a whole bunch of
crazy stuff right they can get they can
lock Trump up right now on
contempt that you don't you don't need a
reason for that they can he can come in
and and he can and Trump he can wait for
Trump to say anything hey watch your
tone with me if you do that again I'm
going to hold you in contempt right and
then Trump says okay fine I I warned you
lock him up bayth they could play
whatever shady games they want now
granted he's got cameras in the
courtroom so he's trying to be a movie
star here because he's a psychopath but
uh we'll see how that plays out I just
think people many people on the right
Libertarians post liberals Etc keep
thinking they're playing they're playing
a game of chess you know where it's like
okay well you know I know the rules you
know the rules you do the best move I'll
do the best move meanwhile they're
sitting back and they've got like five
Queens and they're like What's that over
there and they put a queen on the board
and it's like how do you have two queens
it's like what do you
mean just normal yeah it's like they
changed the rules last year you can now
have five Queens yeah what do you mean
last year we agreed we all agreed yeah I
mean why don't you have five Queens oh
that's too bad I win right it's like
playing Monopoly where the person who's
the banker keeps pulling extra money out
and you're like you're cheating I'm like
no I'm not yeah guys we voted last ruled
on this last turn it's okay new rules
guys
we and he also has the gag order in the
DC case it was put on on hold today for
a little bit but he also yeah it was
what you can put a gag order on hold for
a little bit Yeah so judge Tanya shutkin
who actually
uh uh oversaw the cases of a number of
January 6 defendants and sentenced them
to longer than the Department of Justice
was even asking for said that the gag
order in that case that's the j6 case
would remain on hold while she considers
Trump's um suggestion that he should be
allowed to speak speak freely about the
case what yeah so she had issued the gag
order on Monday which prevented him from
speaking publicly um by targeting
prosecutors or anyone on staff or
Witnesses wow and it's a very serious
restriction it's the most serious
restriction that they've had so far in
any of the cases Trump's attorneys um
appealed it and so now they're now
they're just like hanging on for a
minute Trump's lawyers called it
egregious and
intolerable saying by restricting
president Trump's Free Speech the gag
order eviscerates the rights of his
audiences including hundreds of millions
of American citizens who the court now
forbids from listening to president
Trump's thoughts on important issues
that's crazy that's actually a great
point it's only getting started and that
is what he says right like they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
I'm just in the way and Trump's Bas
loves those insults too like they love
they're a lot of fun they're funny
they're the best part I thought Trump's
tweets were the best part of trump and
they're them trying to stop that you
know it's unacceptable and I love how
like I mean Biden keeps making
everything worse and worse and on
Twitter people keep going hey all
wouldn't it be nice to just have some
Mean Tweets hey Mean Tweets were the
best part true it's true yeah I mean
their argument was but but the Mean
Tweets mhm and so you're like no new
Wars but the Mean
Tweets were withdrawing from the active
Wars but the Mean Tweets and then it's
just like a lot of people were like but
we like the Mean Tweets exactly they're
great and it's just because he was just
an ordinary person saying things that we
all were thinking and I thought like I
think my favorite one was like the the
Rosie O'Donald one and like she got
really mad and no was it Megan Kelly
asked him about it like because I think
he caught her like really insulting and
she was like oh you called women this
and he said no just Rosie and it was
really funny it was it was one of the
Epic moments of trump um I think that's
one of his our favorite Parts there's
like whole Shane Gill bit about how he
just went up there and started you know
attacking every was like whoa you can do
this like this is like they can be your
thing it's like yeah it can be yeah and
I'll give it to Ted Cruz he was a good
sport I'm pretty sure like Trump told
him like his like wife was ugly or
something and like then he turned around
lion Ted oh yeah he insulted him so bad
but you know what Li in like Roar like
Ling like he called him lying Ted and
then after uh like Ted got behind Trump
all the Trump Sports start saying lie
in AAR yep yeah he was a good sport he
didn't sto in line and endorsed him it
was good I actually Ted Cruz I respect
him for that I don't know what the the
disantis campaign thinks they're doing I
mean you but the crazy like I keep
hearing people we have a lot of people
come on the show and we've had some
people who are not
and they're going why are the disantis
people attacking me and I'm like what'
you say like I I haven't said anything
about them and I'm
like dude the disantis people are trying
to lose that's the only thing I can say
yeah what's amazing is they keep giving
ammunition to Joe Biden yeah maybe
that's the point I don't know yikes yeah
they uh see I liked d santis as a
governor I thought he was a great
Governor he did a great job during you
know coid and everything but it was just
the standard it wasn't like he was doing
like Superior things that like set apart
like that is what the standard should
have been Governors should have kept
their states open they should have not
put masks on kids they shouldn't have
closed the schools down closed the
churches just because Dan santis didn't
do that doesn't make him special it
means he was upholding the standard and
you know I respect him doing that uh
especially because a lot of Republicans
sold out during that time however you
know it's a character flaw Donald Trump
drug him across the Finish Line in his
election to put him where he was and
this is how you treat them you know it
was I think that uh it was a a character
flaw on his behalf I think that um he
should remain Governor the people of
Florida need him and I don't think that
he needs to have higher aspirations at
least not
yet so that's my opinion I thought he
could have been a shoe in for for the
next goor round you know yep he should
have been he should have been VP and
then Presidential candidate next time
around that that was the path if he had
ran on hey this is my record this is
what I've done this is what um you know
my conservative record which is strong
hey I'm just here because Donald Trump
might get arrested you know like he was
just running as like a the high
heel that's that's that's that's that's
campaign ending I missed this part of
the news cycle what happened with that
oh he's wearing lifts it's like that
Seinfeld episode remember where uh where
where they they said to the guy who was
like the the body double for one of the
kids on a TV show Mickey was Mickey and
they're like Mickey's wearing lifts he's
lifts in his he's heightening yeah no
don't and on Seinfeld he was heightening
because oh this was growing what is this
this definitely looks like he's wearing
lifts right here are they just weird C
what are those no because it makes his
his lower leg look really yeah right
like Chris angeling it weird it's very
weird yeah that's it there it is
too oh
man yeah that's damning for me like okay
so
look so there's no foot here in the
front of the boot and it's just like
dude yeah have you ever worn like cowb
boots it looks like he's just putting
his foot halfway and his heel is sitting
right on the on the end of the boot
right there you know what I mean like
hold on he should really on the left
look how long his fibula is it's weird
man there's no way dude I don't know you
can argue that it's distorted or
whatever but I think when you can you
can tell there's no foot in the upper
Boot and the pressure on the front of
the boot looks like the top of his foot
it does this this it looks like an
accurate drawing of what he's doing yeah
that's what it looks like look how long
his leg would be if it was like
yeah that's crazy his leg would be
massive dude this guy just I don't know
I feel bad for him I feel bad for him
because I thought he did a good job yeah
this looks like he's on his tippy toes
imagine halfway put on your boot and
going on national TV come on bro yeah
that'
be you can you can get away with doing
like a 2in heel lift inside your shoe
but whatever he's going for is just he
like standing on Tippy toiles man yeah
also like why do you need it well yeah
height height matters no question yeah
that much it matters that much yep
absolutely that's why what didn't didn't
someone want a box to stand on when
Trump they want to debate Trump or
something like
that M Bloomberg yeah Bloomberg Bo he is
short as he's very not against Trump
though but in the debate he wanted to
box to because he's a little thing if
you're open about it not try it's when
you try hide it it's all a numbers game
and so the individual doesn't matter you
can come out and say I know you're all
reasonable right they'll like yeah but
it doesn't matter because if 1% of
people factor in height you lose so
that's why uh uh everybody everybody
knows like the game played by
politicians and if you have you guys
ever seen that U movie The Adjustment
Bureau maybe uh it sounds familiar it's
fun fun movie with Matt Damon where
basically there's a bunch of I guess you
you call them Angels who control
people's Destinies and are guiding
people and manipulating and so Matt
Damon is running for Senate and he loses
and then they're like we need to okay he
lost that's good because we want him to
run again and win later so they're like
now we're going to get him back on track
they influence him he goes out to give
his concession speech and then he just
gets tired of it and he's like okay and
he just he's like see this tie we
actually spent $5,000 to figure out what
the you know what tie I should wear and
he's like you know we actually have a
consultant telling us what the right
amount of scuff on a shoe should be
$15,000 like just basically breaking it
all down but that's the game they play
they probably went to panels and showed
Ronda Santa speaking without the lifts
and with the lifts and found that there
was a massive benefit to wearing lifted
shoes lifted boots he's allegedly
wearing these things I believe it is
fair to say he is because it looks like
he's standing on a sippy toes in this
picture and his leg looks too long in
this picture you know looks like he's
levitating it does like
like does it funny thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net